[Music]
some days like i can't even stand to be
touched like my husband will come home
and give me a hug and i'm just like i
literally will cringe and pull away and
it's like just like don't touch me what
do i do
[Laughter]
don't touch me
[Music]
remember that song i love it hey what's
up this is the dalone dr john delony
show i'm john
so glad you're here remember is that
that's blur right
i couldn't tell you oh my gosh you kids
born in the 2000s hey we're so glad
you're here we're talking about mental
health and relationships and schools and
teachers and whatever's going on in your
mind whatever's going on in your hearts
and minds i'm so glad that you're here
if you want to be on the show give me a
call
1-844-6 three thirty two ninety one it's
four
at
one eight four four six nine three three
two nine one or go to johndaloni.com
ask
a s
k
and
i got somebody else that told me hey
yours is the only podcast i can't listen
to at 1.5 speed because i talk too fast
so for you all
thank you for being here all right let's
go to eric in west salem what's up eric
hey doctor john how are you doing today
dude we are
rocking on to the break of dawn what's
up man how are you
i love it hey i can just say that i'm
doing a whole lot better than my march
madness brackets that i filled out for
this basketball tournament is there is
there anybody whose bracket
still exists surely not i don't i don't
think so no
there's some weird kid with a laptop
that's probably got one still hanging in
there because he ai did cheater but yeah
the rest of it yeah there's no more
brackets
yeah there's there's no way but hey i i
appreciate you reaching out and uh
taking my question today of course man
so what's up how can i help
um just give a little bit of background
context before i get to my question
i'm 29 years old
and i've been a teacher for seven years
at a public school
and the reason why i'm calling today
is because ever since the pandemic has
hit
i struggle with burnout from work
and
it's taken not only a mental toll on me
but a physical toll on me so
i just wanted to see what you had to say
when it comes to being burned out
and just kind of trying to balance home
and
work life man yes thanks for calling and
yeah there's there's a few
a few professions that have shouldered
the burden the last few years and
teachers are for sure one of them uh
what grade do you teach
i teach second grade oh gosh
i got the young ones so fun teaching
literacy and
numeracy online and then in person
they're back online in the back online
and then a person
to seven-year-olds golly and
eight-year-olds i guess
well the in the year before that i
taught kindergarten so they so i taught
my first five years were first grade
thought i was going to be like super
superman go to kindergarten be like this
kindergarten
teacher and
it was god's way of telling me now you
need to teach the younger
older kids
i spent one year as a k-5 p.e teacher
and i have a lifetime of stories so next
time you're in nashville we'll hang out
and we'll just exchange stories some of
the most chaotic hilarious
just wild it's just they're mayhem and
they're they're so it's such an
incredible age i love it um but it's
it's a lot all right so when you say you
just can't
yeah your mental health is struggling
your physical health is struggling
uh unwind that for me a little bit
so
um
there was one morning
this school year about maybe three weeks
ago four or three three months i'm sorry
three weeks ago
a month ago
where i
had an awful anxiety panic attack
um
i ended up leaving school for the day
laying in bed for
three hours and that's actually the day
that i reached out to you guys okay um
so i kind of wrote down some reasons of
why i feel
burnt out and i think that when i get
burnt out it
ends up causing the anxiety and
stuff like that so so real real quick
real quick as we go into this
think of it this way and this is an
oversimplification and this isn't every
case but often often often
think of stress as a
as a relatively good thing stress helps
direct our
our actions what do we do next right so
if i'm stressed about a test i can quit
the class i can drop out of class or i
can study really hard
um if i'm stressed about whether
um she's gonna uh i that person would
ever go out with me i can hide and run
or i can ask her out and just figure it
out right so stress
helps us direct action it also when it
accumulates on us um becomes toxic and
painful it can kill us
and
when you nailed it so i want to make
sure you hear me say you were right on
it's when we that stuff continues to
pile up and pile up and pile up and we
don't deal with it and our bodies are
fighting and fleeing and going and going
and spinning up and spinning down and
spinning up and spinning down and we
don't do it that's when our body starts
sending alarms like anxiety like a panic
at that's when that's when the system's
over overflow right so you wrote down
some things which is always the great
first step what have you come up with
so i came up with learning the ins and
outs of a new grade level which i would
say i did it to myself a lot of these
things are self-inflicted
so well let's let's let's don't start
judging them beating them up yet just
just rattle them off for me
okay so learning the ins and outs of a
new grade level okay trying trying to
stay ahead of the game with lesson prep
okay
struggling with baggage
that multiple students bring through my
door each and every day
their home lives that they're coming
with and also at the same time trying to
balance
the
state standards i'm trying to get those
met
and then bringing the energy myself to
motivate students to want to learn okay
so that's acute
that is show up every day right
back out of that
one one ring
um okay how are you eric taking care of
eric like what's your day look like
so i get up um
probably around 5 30 give or take each
day okay i spent some time in the word
um and then i jump in the shower eat
breakfast talk to my wife
and depending on if the kids are up or
not i get to kiss them goodbye
um and then head to school my wife's
so awesome she's so supportive in
my work life
i get to school about an hour hour 15
before the students show up
it gives me time to kind of prep for my
day get things done i need to get done
um
school day goes by
um i get home around four
and that's something else i kind of want
to bring up was that when i come home i
am just mentally drained and so i come
home
you know i have a wife at home that's
missed me all day i have kids that want
to climb and play with dad
and there's days where
i feel more energetic like i can do it
and then there's others days where i
feel completely guilty and horrible
because
i just want to sit and scroll i want to
decompress i want to get away from
you know the work
and just kind of take a break in a sense
so somebody along the way told you
that
um
your
the way you feel about things the way
you think about things doesn't matter
who told you that who modeled that for
you
can we can you re-ask questions sorry i
didn't understand the first time um
somebody along the way whether it was
your dad or your mom or
somebody you cared about or whatever
somebody modeled for you
that
your thoughts don't matter
that you the way you feel doesn't matter
that your responsibility is everybody
else
that's a great question i
i honestly don't know my mom and dad
were very supportive
um very supportive growing up
you know they always took the time to
praise
when i did things well okay let's jump
in on that okay okay because often when
i say where'd you model that people
instantly go to and i do this too
who screwed up and it's often not that
so let's say
that
when you
helped out around the house
or you were part of a service project
your parents stopped what they were
doing and they told you how wonderful
you were
and then at school if you
got good grades they stopped the presses
and took you out to dinner if you it you
know
did something for the team whatever the
thing was
what can happen over time is you equate
your body equates and i want to make
this a characteristic your body equates
when i
do things for other people
i get rewards
and over time
i'm going to keep doing those things
even to the detriment of what i need
right now which is a break
what i want to do which is go to law
school instead of education school i'm
just making stuff up right um even if i
need to take two days off of work
because i'm on the edge of having a
breakdown
even like fill in the blank
even well-meaning incredible wonderful
parents
who want to make sure they catch you
doing right catch you doing good
can set you on a path towards
the way to be loved is achievement
and
a varying form of achievement is service
to other people you see what i'm saying
yeah i'm not saying that happened in
your case
i always just want to peel the layer
back because here's what you're telling
me
that you wake up in the day
you owe something to god
followed by you'll have some breakfast
then you owe something to your kids and
your wife
then for eight hours you owe something
to a room of
of second graders
and somewhat to their families because
you're also a social worker when you're
a second grade teacher
and then you get home
and you just need like a few minutes to
recalibrate
and if you are not immediately giving
that to becoming a human jungle gym for
your family then boom we have looped
back and now your body has a shame cycle
that it starts like how dare you what do
you mean you get little kids who do you
think you are
you see what i'm saying
right and so
think of burnout this way all and this
comes from the great nagatsky sisters
all burnout is is your body saying i'm
out i'm done
because i've been put repeatedly in
stressful situations in situations that
i can't win situations that
i'm disconnected i'm alone and there's
very few jobs lonelier than an
elementary school teacher most people
don't know that you have little grade
level teams which are fine
those can be somewhat competitive too if
you've ever been with the pinterest
teacher crew
um
um you know what i'm talking about
yeah but you it's an isolating job it's
an adult with a
20 second graders or 30 second graders
or 40 second graders depending on the
funding of your school district
and so it's just it's a drain every
every ounce of your body leaves uh
leaves you
and then you come home and you have to
be present for your wife and kids so
your body is saying
dude we we're out
and most people think we're out means i
need to quit my job or they think i need
to stop being a nurse or a surgeon or an
attorney or a pastor or a teacher
and that's often not the case sometimes
it is sometimes the systems are so
screwed up and so toxic that they do
right but often it's a sign that we're
not taking care of ourselves
and i can totally agree with that okay
for sure and so i would love to
challenge you
on a couple of things
you have a morning routine which is
awesome i would challenge you to tweak
that a little bit
and maybe instead of sitting down in the
dark and reading your bible or reading a
book or whatever
switch it to an audiobook switch it to
some sort of um
some sort of audio thing and then go for
a walk or go exercise it doesn't have to
be crossfit go do something to move your
body
okay and then in the evenings
you get off at four
i would suggest try this for 30 days
this may be a disaster okay
i want you to take it awesome i want you
to take the hour between four and five
for you
that might mean go to a coffee shop
that might mean stop at a gym at the way
home i mean be joining a jiu jitsu i
don't care what it is go bowling i don't
care
but for 30 days i want you to practice
and what you're gonna find i'm guessing
is that our investment in eric
allows you enough capital to then run
all the way to through the finish line
of that day
okay see what i'm saying
yes sir and i really don't call me sir
come on i'm sorry i don't even have a
cane i don't have a beard or nothing
um
the uh
the investment in yourself is gonna pay
off all the way through the end of the
evening even to the point you can get
through bedtimes and all kind of stuff
what you're gonna have to be weary of is
that shame voice i shouldn't be here
right now
i should be at home i should and that's
what you gotta write down right now oh
yeah i'm hearing it right now because
could i like say that my wife is like a
huge quality time person so like
it's almost like when i get off from
school it's like she gets that break
which she does deserve because she's
with the kids all day
let's don't say let's don't do it in
deserve okay okay okay once you get into
the deserve language like i deserve this
and you deserve that that's a recipe for
competition
right so let's take that language away
and let's say
i want to meet her needs
so that she can meet my needs so that i
can then show up and meet her needs
i promise you any spouse in the worth
their salt which is definitely your wife
would rather
an hour
of
full you then two hours of your your
half in and half out
or two hours of one and a half of those
hours as you complaining about second
grade parents and their dumb thing i
can't believe i got the testing going on
hey timmy i'm talking to mom right now
come back in a minute oh and then this
happened
you see what i'm saying
yes sir she would much rather you
go grab a quick drink or chips and queso
with a couple of buddies from four to
five
once a week and show up at home or go
work out or go for a run or a walk or
something and then show up at five with
sleeves rolled up what is up and i'm
here
you know what i mean
yes because i'm fully on and sit down
and talk with her maybe it's 45 minutes
maybe it's till five maybe it's it's 90
minutes
here's what i'm getting at
you may be like cooked
there's no question um what you've had
to endure as a second grade teacher as a
kindergarten teacher the last few years
i mean god help you dude i mean it's
been bonkers
the state demands the
parental demands the unfunded mandate
demands it's just never ends for
teachers so make no mistake and you
don't make enough money to
work 12 hours a day plus worry about it
all night okay
um
that's where we find ourselves with
education public education this is what
it is
it sounds like though you have
made your life a journey about helping
other people and i want you to put your
oxygen mask on first for a season and
give it a shot
okay
this means you're gonna be intentional
and i know yeah i know you can't
does that does that sound like something
you i know you can will you for just 30
days
yes yep i will i will commit to that for
sure all right so tell your wife you met
with some knucklehead on a pot no i'm
not doing that anymore positive
self-talk you met with a kind guy on a
podcast
and i recommend it i want you to try it
for 30 days and if you will loop back
and let us know
my guess is you're going to sleep a
little bit better your sex life's going
to get better you're going to be more
plugged in with your kids you're gonna
feel better
and
you're gonna be able to let stuff roll
off a little bit when you get to the
office
um so the main focus is here sleep
movement
um
getting some time to stop at a coffee
shop and or grab a drink with some
friends some community time it's not
your wife and it's not your kids
and some journaling time to get some of
this stuff out so you can move on and
then get come home just ready to rock
and roll love it eric your family
family's lucky to have you those kids
are lucky to have you and everybody
listening that's a teacher
got to figure out ways to support and
love those teachers we'll be right back
for too long we've avoided the hard
conversations about mental health
relationships and the food we eat and i
don't want it to be true either but it
is the quality and quantity of the food
that we put into our body it matters and
oftentimes we're forced to decide
between cheap food that's good for our
budget or expensive food that's good for
our family but there's a company that
solved the problem greensbury is a
family-owned meat provider working with
farmers and fishermen all over the
country they sell organic grass-fed beef
free-range poultry pork lamb bison and
sustainable seafood their meat is less
expensive than what i can get at the
grocery store right down the street and
they deliver it to my door now listen
i'm a lunatic about meat quality and
this is the stuff i feed my family so go
to
greensbury.com and you'll get 10 off
your first purchase check it out today
your nutrition is worth it
all right hey as we come back in
just a quick note for teachers
um
you all know i work here with ramsey
solutions not some not all of you know
that some of you don't um i work here
with ramsey solutions and one thing
about this company is we really care
about people's finances and how people
take care of their money and how that
stress leads over to their marriages
into their work and it's their lives etc
etc and we also really really love
teachers and as i just pointed out in
that last segment teachers have been
grinding it out for year after year
especially the last two three years
so it's teachers like
like eric who i don't know if he's
taught it but his teachers like you hear
that voice i'm just trying to do the
best i can try and do lesson plans that
teach our foundations and personal
finance course for folks that millions
and millions of kids have gone through
april is national financer financial
literacy month and we're celebrating
teachers like eric with our teacher
appreciation giveaway sponsored by the
borrowed future documentary teachers can
enter today to win some cash cash
this is so good
cashed
it reminds me ben of that uh there's a
great old movie remember what it is but
they're like
you know money doesn't buy happiness and
they were they were taking one of those
uh bus tours through hollywood looking
at all the big houses
and there was just people out mindlessly
watering their yards they're like you
think those people are happy
and the people on the bus were all like
no and he goes what are you talking
about look how happy they're delirious
you know why because they're rich and
that just made me laugh it's not really
but it kind of makes me feel good hey
teachers we're not gonna make you rich
but we're gonna give you
cash five thousand dollars cash to a
couple of lucky teachers and then other
teachers will win up to thousand dollars
cash and more so don't miss out teachers
go to
ramseysolutions.com teacher for a chance
to win all right let's go to nicole in
indianapolis what's up nicole
oh nothing much how are you dude we are
dancing on the ceiling lionel richie
style what's up
okay well i'm super nervous so hopefully
i don't screw up um have you ever
listened to this show
frequently yeah i'm not that good either
we're good same team what's up what's up
okay
i'm gonna throw a lot at you so
hopefully
it's all it all makes sense
um you know i've been married i've been
married for almost 10 years my husband
is a new uh pastor
like within the last
sorry two years um he is visually
impaired
um
[Music]
like percentage-wise probably about 90
percent like he's got some light
perception okay um
but he uses his cane to get around and
um guides off of me and
people in unfamiliar places okay so so
yeah he's not getting around restaurants
he's not driving anything like that yeah
correct okay all right cool um
i'm a mom to a one and a half year old
i'm a stay-at-home mom
i run a women's bible study i babysit
another toddler two times a week i
actually just started door dashing a
couple times a week to help
make bring some extra money home i cook
i clean i do laundry
and by the end of the day i'm just
completely exhausted and burnt out and
um too tired for sex and other intimacy
um and some days like i can't even stand
to be touched like my husband will come
home and give me a hug and i'm just like
i literally will cringe and pull away
and it's like just
like don't touch me i've been touched
all day
what do i do
[Laughter]
don't touch me
i made that mistake before yeah this is
hard um
could i ask you hard questions
yes
like we're on the dial
from 10 being
kind of brutal hard questions and one
being like hey what's the weather like
um be
be brutally honest okay
hat is your husband's eyesight been
degenerative or has it been that way
since you you all been together
um so we
have
been together since
2009
and when
we met it was pretty much right at the
height of his um vision loss he's always
been visually impaired since he was
really little
but that steep the steepest rate of
decline was
that junior year of high school through
freshman sophomore year of his college
um
so when i i've always known him as a
blind person
and
yeah so he was pretty much where he is
now back when we met
so
some of the
some of the just the innate challenge of
having a one and a half year old your
body's not yours still
yeah and you're a human jungle gym
and you are a
human um grocery store and you're a
human and somebody has to watch you go i
remember the first time my wife was gone
and my son was really young and i had to
go to the bathroom and i didn't know i
was like oh
i i guess you're coming in like i didn't
know what i mean
that thought had never occurred to me
and
so somebody stares at you while you go
to the bathroom or talks to you worse i
don't talk to anybody in the back right
it never stops
and so some of this
a lot of this is you have a one and a
half year old
and i would tell you to give yourself a
lot of grace okay i would tell you to
have conversations about that with your
husband speak it out loud
underneath that this is a harder
question and just be honest with being
yourself
and
i'm not leading you i'm just asking a
question a lot of folks that i know who
have romantic relationships or kids with
special needs
both love
the the the things that make their
partner unique or their kids unique and
it's really frustrating
and it's super annoying and i just god
can you just go get your own diet coke
but nope you can't you know what i mean
how much of that plays into now that you
have a one and a half year old now
there's a new job now you're trying to
pay off debt
it's like god almighty i don't know
where the toilet paper is can you just
but i gotta go get that too because in
many ways it's like having a second
young person in the house right
yeah i think
i hadn't
put a whole lot of thought into it um
but
yeah like before we had we were together
for
i'm not great at math but like eight
plus years before we had a baby
um so it's like before the baby it's
like oh yeah that's fine you know drive
you where you need to go go get that
thing
help you read the menu it's like it's
not a thing but now it's like when we go
places it's like i've got
this
little child who can't do anything for
himself
um
and but i still have to help my husband
too so
i hadn't i hadn't put a whole lot of
thought into that
and you avoided the question like a like
a ninja so you don't even have to you
don't have to answer it but but hang on
to it okay okay
i want to free you're allowed to be
frustrated and you're allowed to be
really annoyed
and you're allowed to be pissed off that
your husband
is that he is sight impaired it's okay
it's when you take it out on him then
that's where i would challenge your
actions and stuff like that but it's
okay and a lot of people beat themselves
up for those those lightning bolt
thoughts
and like god dude
oh she could just drive himself to the
freaking grocery store
um and i got to figure out how to do
this with my this schedule and that
schedule now i got a one and a half girl
he's got to eat and if after he eats if
i don't get him down then it turns into
a whole thing
and then husband's used to the old days
where he were basically his uber service
right
so
you've heard me talk about this a lot
this happens with all people who have
their first kid
and
that they have this first kid and not
everybody in the house is on the same
page with how much has changed
and so in your home 100 of everything
has changed all of it every second of
your life has changed and so instead of
getting frustrated to him getting
frustrated because he has lived a
certain way for eight years he's coming
to depend on you and you on him and
you'll have a great rhythm and that
rhythm is now different forever it's
gone forever
and now you have this new baby and so
it's gonna have conversations about we
really want to get out of debt but this
isn't the six months to do this
we need to make some extra income
we're going to figure out another way
because i can't do dinner and this and
this or
we're going gonna have to get some help
around here i'm gonna have to have a
college student come over after hours
and watch the kid while i do this so
that i can right so we're gonna have to
be very intentional about here's my
capacity
because you can't do what you were and
just dump a one and a half year old on
top of all of it and deal with a new job
that's a ministerial job that takes
a whole family to do often anyway
you know what i mean
yeah
and then
now we're to the sex part
to the intimacy part what's going on
there
um oh
that's so awkward i have never like
compared to my husband i've never had as
high of a sex drive as him so
sometimes it's a little more of a chore
for me it's like well you know gotta get
him what he
gotta get him what he needs um
i try to be intentional about it but
it's different when it's when you have a
baby and it's like i've been on the go
all day
um
so
we've had some conversations about it
we've had you know like these are you
know my needs like
i
we we obviously can't write letters to
each other but we did an email um and i
said these are some of my needs you know
i
you know abc and then he actually did
the same thing he sent me an email with
some of his needs and
um
it was just a
just
um here's what i want you to do i want
you all to get the book together
and read it's called come as you are
by emily nagotsky
um and i want you able to read that book
together and there's gonna be parts of
that book that are like whoa
um and it is it is it is not
it's written for women
but one of the things it's um it's been
eye opening for every guy i know that's
read it in a in a positive way
and in particular
she does a great job peeling apart the
myth that sex is a drive that some
people just have more than the other
what she proves
physiologically is that sex's act sex
drive if you will is actually a series
of
gas pedals and breaks
and what every couple's that women's sex
drive is not men's sex drive light
that it's just different entirely and if
you will focus more on the brakes and
the gas pedals instead of this myth
about well i just don't like it as much
or
women just feel this way or guys just
everybody's different and if you think
about the breaks and the gas pedals and
she walks it through in a remarkable way
um i finished that book and i recommend
it to everybody i
i mean oh my counselor for everybody i
thought needs to read this it's just a
great book on sex and intimacy for women
but as a guy i read it and i was like oh
my gosh i didn't know half this you know
what i mean so
it's a great book to open conversations
there are parts of that book that'll be
awkward for you to sit with your husband
and read no question about that and by
the way you've already made a human
we're past awkward at this point right
we're married um so let's have some
grown-up conversations but i think that
would be a great
it's it's a step beneath the the needs
conversation what do you need what do i
need this is more
how do i create a world for you
where
you are free to run wild with desire
with intimacy with rest
with all these really with connection
these really important things that we
don't give ourselves permission because
we just add another job and another
payment to a thing and another car and
we just keep going and going and going
and this gives this book is great
languages come as you are by emily emily
nagotsky um
this is probably gonna mean
that you'll have to get some help around
your house for a season
and that
can make you feel like you're not enough
that can make you both feel like we
can't afford this
i'm gonna tell you that a little bit of
help in your life
will
pay
the investment in a little bit of help
whether that's someone to clean your
house once a month or once every two
weeks
and it's just a high school kid can you
come take out the trash and vacuum you
don't have to do the baseboards or
anything crazy
um can you watch
little timmy while i go and do what like
what getting some help
will be huge hey honey instead of me
picking you up you're going to start
getting an uber ride
and i know that sounds like not sexy and
romantic but this is where we are right
now you got a full-time job and i am
working and i'm at home and i got a baby
so let's get creative and let's take off
all of the
well we can't and we shouldn't and that
just doesn't make sense and that doesn't
look right we're past all that stuff now
now we're trying to do is continue to
love each other in this brand new season
it's just going to take us to think
differently not just do the same things
we've always been harder and faster got
what i'm saying
how does that sound
we have a lot of it it sounds like at
the surface level it's like oh yeah
that's doable i know
this person and this person and this
person will all love to watch
the baby and it's like
that's so hard for me personally that's
a whole other call that that's it's like
accepting defeat but like i know it's
not but that's how it feels like oh i
can't do all these things no answer
answer is no you cannot yeah yeah
guess what nicole
you need help
and support
and i haven't even yeah it's a whole
call we haven't even gotten into hey you
got to make sure you're exercising too
and you got to make sure you have time
for you to eat right and to
write and to read and to think and to
not just try to duct tape each day
together so you can get the next one and
then super glue that one so you get to
the next one and then wrap an extension
quarter on that once you get to the next
one your life is worth more than this
so much more
so even before you have the help
conversation let's have a you've had the
needs conversation let's take let's go
let's make that thing bigger
new season we're building something
totally new totally different what do we
want this to look like well honey i
really liked it when you picked me up
every day well that's not happening
cause we made a kit
so i like it when you're home at five so
we're gonna set this side this much
budget money for uber rides and two
hours a day three days a week i'm going
to have somebody come over and watch the
kid while i'm even there and by the way
my elementary school son he goes to he's
gone he hasn't done it recently but he
goes to people's house
while mom is home and there's just a
two-year-old and they play together so
it's kind of like in-house babysitting
so she can get stuff done or he can dad
can get stuff done while they're at home
but they don't have to have they had
ears on the kid but they don't have eyes
on the kid right something small like
that but you need some help and this
isn't about defeat this is about victory
okay it's not about weakness or you
didn't make it this is about oh yeah
we're definitely gonna make it and i'm
gonna start delegating because that's
how that's how much of a baller we are
okay but let's picture what we want this
thing to look like
grab that book and you'll read it
together we'll link to it in the show
notes
um it's not a faith book or anything
like that i mean it's a clinical book
and it's a direct book
but let's get into it and let's learn
what the gas pedals are and the brakes
are in our home
and the intimacy level should rise to
how you want it to be
and hopefully how he wants it to be and
y'all can meet there in the middle
awesome nicole you're the best we'll be
right back
do you want a better life a better
marriage better mental and physical
health the single most important action
you can take to improve your mental and
physical health to change your entire
life is to get enough deep restorative
quality sleep i know this from research
and as a guy who has struggled with
sleep for my entire life and for me good
sleep starts with a world-class mattress
that's why my family sleeps on dream
cloud mattress dream cloud is advanced
technology and you can buy it in the
store or you can do it like i did and
have it shipped directly to your house
dreamcloud is running their biggest
offer ever exclusively for dr john
doloni's show listeners 399 bucks and
accessories plus an additional 250
discount that's a total of
649 dollars in accessories and savings
pillows mattress protectors luxury
sheets all of it it's time to stop
sleeping on your old college mattress or
the old hand me down from grandma and
start changing your life visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep and enter
promo code deloney and get your new
mattress today
all right we are back let's go to daisy
in the city of angels what's up daisy
hi how are you i'm so good how are you
um blue well thanks for having me of
course what's up
okay so
here we go um about a year ago my mom
passed away oh my gosh what happened
she got sick it was cold related but
then underlying diseases and
yeah it just happened really quick in
two days like she was gone daisy i'm so
sorry
yeah and
um so she was
fostering um on the process in the
process to adopt my three nieces okay um
they're all under the age of seven so
it's seven four and three
and um they're my brother's daughters he
he and their mom are both addicts so
they're not in the picture
um so when that happened um
my sister and i we were living in the
same home as my nieces and my mom so we
took over
but i'm 26 and my sister is 30.
talk right into the phone daisy yeah um
yeah so she has her own son and
i'm 26 without kids so you know we kind
of didn't know what to do we spent four
months with them
um
then their mom's family from out of
state called and
they fought for them in court they took
my nieces with them
out of state and um
they were out there for about four
months we went out there to visit my
nieces you know i missed them like crazy
and you know i basically grew up with
them and um
suddenly
i get a call i'm at work and i get a
call from social services and they're
like well you know your nieces are back
to la and
they're in the foster care system with
you know random family what happened
i guess their family in texas wasn't
able to care for them anymore because
they had like their own kids and they
didn't really prepare they just kind of
suddenly took them
yeah and you know i love them so as soon
as i heard that i was like i need to get
i need to get on it and i need to fight
for them like
meaning the world to me
um
and aside from that i've been with my
boyfriend for a long time and you know
we're starting our life together we're
eventually planning on having our own
kids and all that but
i've always been hesitant because i
kind of never wanted kids i always felt
like i
you know i do so much with my research
and all of that and i just didn't want
to be
i don't know it's just a lot so what's
your what's your question yeah how can i
help oh sounds like a mess well
my
now that i'm taking custody of them in
two weeks oh wow so you filed for
custody and you got it
yeah so you're about to be a mom of a
seven and a four and a what
three-year-old
dang gina
wow
good for you okay so it's it's happening
it's happening and um
my boyfriend is not on board
oh
daisy daisy
okay so how can i help
i i feel like you know he i love him he
means the world to me i always come my
whole entire life with him so
now that i've made this choice and i've
decided to take it on take on my nieces
and
you know like try to
you know provide a better
life for them
is
how do i get over the fact that he may
not be in my life anymore just because
of this choice that i have what a
heartbreaking and great question
great question
all right so i'm just going to tell you
the truth all the way through is that
cool
yeah
what you've done is one of the most
extraordinary
noble sacrificial things i've ever heard
of and
it's going to be very very very hard
yeah
the
statistics tell me
that you are going to have to be real
clear and real precise in your next
steps
or you'll end up in poverty with three
young kids
yeah right and you know this do you have
a degree do you have a trade what do you
do
yeah i'm an accountant ah
some okay so you're ahead of the game
i hope so no you are um what's your
annual income
um about 65 000. daisy's getting it
what does knucklehead make what's your
boyfriend make and i just called
knuckles he's probably an awesome guy
yeah he makes about um ninety thousand
dang gina y'all are crushing okay
getting it okay
so
um
dang
so here's here's the
he feels like you chose them over him
yes not them with him
right
and
have you all sat down and had that
conversation this isn't about them
versus you this is about what's right
yes and he knows that that's the right
choice but he feels like he he can't be
a part of it because he's not ready and
he's used to having a certain lifestyle
and now he knows that's going to change
and so now it flips back on you which
sounds like he's choosing lifestyle over
the woman though he's going to spend the
rest of his life with
yes
if that's the case
if that's truly the case and i'm not
certain that it is
then you have like the matrix dodged a
bullet
and i'm so glad you dodged it
because this would have come up in two
years five years 10 years 15 years
if he is interested in lifestyle over
you that comes up somehow in the wash it
always does
the other side of it is you deserve
somebody who is all in on you
and when you're faced with a hey my
mom's got cancer she's got to move in
with us cool we're gonna figure this out
hey my brother is an addict and he's
known this all along your boyfriend
and that these kids are floating back
and forth and they their heartbeats with
yours is how you feel about them
and
there's always this chance lingering
and
so here we are and he's making a choice
there is no easy simple
heartbreak free path through this
there's just not
and this happens when if you had gotten
pregnant this might have happened
like i'm not i'm not ready for that you
know what i mean yeah yeah i've thought
about exactly that i was like well he's
not with me on this i mean what else
what else what if i would have gotten
pregnant and something's wrong with the
child and he's not there with me that's
right that's what i'm saying you may
have dodged a bullet and you may have
become a single mom with three kids
seven and under and his brain exploded
which i want to give him some grace on
that too
yeah okay
here's the path through this
you have set some things into motion
again
so noble so brave so incredible this is
family legacy shifting stuff
at your funeral there will be hundreds
of people talking about the time you
stepped up when nobody would and gave
these three kids life
okay what you're doing is generational
and it's going to come at a cost okay so
i won't i just want to put that out
there there's no way to keep what was
and to do the right thing in this
situation hear what i'm saying
yeah i understand so here we are we've
done the right thing and it might cost
us and it may cost us but it's not going
to be because we did the right thing
it's going to be because other people
don't want to be a part of our new world
and they have that right
and that breaks our heart and that makes
us weep and that makes us sad and that
doesn't mean that we didn't do the right
thing
okay
that doesn't
help in the middle of the night when
you're super lonely and he's not taking
your calls or you decide not to call
anymore
yeah and that doesn't help when there's
a your three-year-old that needs a
diaper change and a seven-year-old
crying and running around because he
misses mom and dad and grandma it
doesn't in this the third placement in
three years right there's gonna be
challenges on this journey
so much easier
if that guy would call you today and be
like you know what i'm i'm i'm crazy
about you we're getting married this
weekend at the jp and i'm i'm ride or
die
you know what i mean because then you
double and a half your income you've got
a guy who loves you is going to be there
for the kids and unfortunately he said
i'm not in for this ride
so what has to happen sooner rather than
later and you're not going to want to
have this conversation because you're
not going to really want to know the
answer you'll want to know one of the
answers but not the other one
you're going to have to sit down with
them because these kids come in two
weeks
and you need to have the conversation
are you in or are you out
because if you are out i'm not going to
bring another adult in these kids lives
that's going to leave on them
and he might say i'm out
and that will be
that would be devastating right yeah
hello have you had that that thought run
through your head you've looped through
that before haven't you okay so where do
you land on it
i just wouldn't want him to be in and
out of my life and then seeing
that i'm allowing him in and out of my
life because of them only for them to
believe themselves you're so good you're
so good to yourself into those kids
do you have one or two girlfriends that
can walk through this with you
yes i do okay
so here's your next steps number one
rally your girlfriends
and what i mean by rally them i mean get
everybody three five seven of them
cousins i don't care friends whatever
and say
kids are coming in two weeks i need
somebody with kids to help me baby-proof
my house oh by the way do you and this
guy live together
we have for the past four years but i
just got my own place okay
so are y'all already breaking up do you
feel it happening
kind of yeah
is it kind of or is is it over
well it's
it's still the same between us but then
when it's anything
we bring up like my nieces at all he's
kind of like well that's kind of that's
your life and i have my life so when you
say it's just the same that means you'll
still sleep together and you'll still go
to dinner together
yeah
but y'all are broken up
i i don't know it kind of
feels like we're in the middle of
something or like we're kind of avoiding
the topic sometimes there you go so you
gotta have that conversation
okay
you're gonna start drowning soon if
you're not already
yeah i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
all right so three girlfriends four
girlfriends y'all get together
and i want y'all to come up with a
strategy for the next two to three
months
how are we gonna get kids to school
um how are we gonna get kids home how
are we gonna get kids like where do they
go to school how do we even have
conversations with teachers all that
kind of stuff get a couple of friends
who already have kids they're going to
walk you through what happens
i want you to make up a fake morning
routine
everybody gets up at the same time we do
breakfast like this we go to the park on
saturdays at least just for give these
kids some routine and give you some
routine okay right
otherwise you're gonna be it's like a
fire hose
i got two kids that have been with me
for a long time and i don't even know
what day it is some days okay
i'm telling you
so
the second thing you got to do
is have this hard hard conversation
i think if i look at behavior as a
language you've moved out
he's told you pretty clearly that's your
life now which means that's not my life
which means
we're dragging out the physical stuff
here we're dragging out the last like
ellipsis of connection but these things
run its course
and you are hoping praying fingers
crossing rubbing
the genie in a bottle lamps right
that he's going to call you and be like
dude i'm crazy i'm sorry
um
he might not he probably won't i know
i hate that okay you just said it out
loud
does that
wash over your body
yeah i i've kind of noticed it it's just
it's i don't know i i try to avoid i get
thinking about it okay
you're about to have a house full of
three little kids
and i want you to be as plugged in as
you can how long you all been together
nine years oh gosh so this is gonna be
like losing a leg in an arm and part of
your lungs right yes it is
you're worth somebody that will love you
through all of it
yeah
you're right please please don't bring
these three kids into your house and
four months later send them back so that
you can be with somebody
no that's not happening you promise
i promise okay
awesome
and if you look around and say los
angeles is too freaking expensive move
to tennessee or to texas we'd love to
have you here
it's much cheaper
we'll pay you good too and there's no
state income tax you can keep all your
own money it's awesome
it's like a glitch in the matrix
cool
cool
i am so proud of you and at the same
time heartbroken for you
because i think this guy's probably a
good guy i really do and i think he
says whoa i'm not ready to be a dad of
three little kids
and
which makes
here's where the we take separate roads
in the woods and that's that's just hard
i'm so sorry
have the conversation
this week
yeah i will promise
yes not by text daisy
no not my time in person no yelling no
drama
let's just find out where we are because
i'm about to bring three kids home and
if we're not together then cool
um we're not gonna hook up anymore we're
not gonna do dinners anymore we're gonna
take a break for six nine months and
then we can catch up later i i'll always
love you hope you're doing well and you
need to move on with your life if he
hasn't already
yeah and you too oh i'm so sorry
but i will say this
in a world full of people who think
bravery is
putting mean posts on the internet or
creating cool tick-tock videos with
rants in them
bravery looks like a 26 year old
accountant
who's highly successful
who says i'm not letting those three
kids who are got my blood pulsing
through their veins going to the system
i'm gonna figure this out
i'm gonna bring him home even though i
don't know what i'm doing even though
this is not how i drew my life up even
though
it's not not i didn't create this mess
but it landed in my lap
because these kids deserve better
bravery
make sure you get the care you need make
sure you get the the mental health
resources that you need make sure you
got friends in your corner make sure you
got a group of people at a local church
you can lean on you whoever you got a
gang
make sure that you're going for walks
taking care of yourself that you're
figuring out ways that you can sleep
your life's gonna be pretty chaotic for
a while make sure you're meeting with
the teachers of the schools and the
counselors and schools that they can
give you the resources
go all in
and i hope hope hope this guy stands up
and walks alongside you
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll be right back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now is your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
johndaloni.com to start creating the
life you want that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
man
the great sarah brought this album by am
i allowed to say this
everyone thinks they're the greatest
band of all time i do not do you
ah
by the not greatest band of all time
that everyone seems to think they are
songs by the beatles
and it's called help and it goes like
this
i need somebody help not just anybody
help you know i need somebody help
so much younger than today i never need
i never needed anybody's help in any way
but now these days are gone i'm not so
self-assured now i find i've changed my
mind and opened all the doors
help me if you can i'm feeling down find
somebody to help today everybody we'll
see you soon
coming up on the next episode
most people
are not narcissists most people are
jerks my oldest will be 18 pretty soon
and
he has not
handled the loss that well how did how
did dad grieve how did you grieve um to
be honest i don't think we had have had
a chance to okay oppositional defiance
disorder uh i know it's a clinical
diagnosis it seems like it's more of an
excuse
over the last number of years for a lack
of parenting skills
you're asking an either or question is
this real or is this if parents would
just suck it up and start parenting
their kids right this would go away and
the answer is more complex than that i
don't know what to say to my friends
because
saying sorry sounds stupid
in saying i understand i don't i just
want i want to fly there and fight
your guilt
will not help them